but I'm trying to just say it and like
let go of that trauma because I do have
a lot to say it ariana grande is
defending herself against those claims
that she's a diva it kind of jump a
little bit in a new interview with Zane
Lowe on Apple music the 26 year old
singer opened up about why she stepped
out of the spotlight in the past and to
let her music speak for itself I stopped
doing like interviews for a really long
time because I felt like I whenever I
would get into a position where somebody
would try to say something for clickbait
or twist my words or blah blah blah
like I would defend myself and then
people would be like oh she's a diva and
I was like this doesn't make any sense
Ari called out the difference between
men and women saying that if a man
expresses their opinions or defends
themselves they're considered brilliant
but the pop star says that's just not
how it is for women it makes you want to
quiet down a little bit but I'm trying
to also say that I'm just you know I
mean and it can't I'm tired of seeing
women silenced by it
and even though Ari is doing her best to
shake it off she admitted it's still
hard it really sits with you and you
feel like oh wow should I not express
myself anymore and then it's kind of
show up a little bit but I'm trying to
just say it and like let go of that
trauma because I do have a lot to say
and I do enjoy talking to people and I
do want to do interviews and share with
people and not be afraid to be myself
then Ari got emotional when Zane praised
her for letting her work do the talking
that's gonna make me cry thank you I
appreciate that
oh yes yuck sorry I appreciate that a
lot
and of course her work speaks volumes
when et caught up with re at the Grammys
in January she opened up about making
music that helps her heal what does it
mean to be here the Grammys with these
major nominations um it means matches in
honor and it's you know it's insane cuz
you know we didn't really even mean to
really make this album it just kind of
happened because my friends and I were
trying to help ourselves out of a very
trying time very horrible time and it
was kind of an accident
to see
received and celebrated this way is very
nice it's very nice but Ari's most
recent interview wasn't all diva talk we
just wanted to make something fun that
also helps and kind of makes people feel
I think less alone I guess the triple
threat also opened up about her new
single with Justin Bieber stuck with you
proceeds from the sales and streams of
the track will go to the children of
first responders music is the thing that
makes people feel good it's the thing
that speaks most to people's spirits and
we just wanted to lift them
[Music]